it seemed like especially on social
media the main thing
that people were the most reactive to
was batman saying an f-word
and i'm like that represents his moral
compass
that's such a in a different way than
killing people
he's likely to have said that he's a
grown man he's likely to have said
he's under his breath like climbing
stuff just like in the difficulties of
the job
even just without the context of saying
it to another person
i have two rules don't kill
and don't say
in case kids are around to witness
justice i don't want them to be
corrupted by me
it's not a big deal guys
i heard there was a secret cord
that david played and it pleads the
[ __ ] lord
and then he pulled out a gun he uses
guns now the snyder cut
might be rated r this news broke last
night no one's really talking about it
on youtube
but we are that's right might as well
talk about it just a little bit so
here's what
the snyder man had us i call him the
snyder man it's not a man he said here's
one piece of information nobody knows
this movie is insane and so epic
and is probably rated r okay now let's
break this down we already knew it was
insane we already
knew it was epic but we didn't know for
sure
and here's my first thought i thought it
already was written for some reason my
mind went there to go and i didn't think
they would rate it i thought it would
just be more on the our leaning side of
the
hbo miniseries is kind of the impression
i was getting i would do whatever
zack schneider director's cut does which
is be more hardcore and more harsh and
stuff like that
yeah so it wasn't surprising to me
so we didn't like jump right away to
talk about it but then i've had thoughts
about it since i woke up and said that's
one thing i think will happen
that will be an r-rated version for sure
we haven't heard from the npa but that's
my gut there is one
scene where batman drops nf bomb
and the twitter world erupted and i
participated
too why not i started thinking about it
i'm like you know i think people are
expecting like a hard f
like you know stepping you got to be
the way youtube is you gotta be careful
such a casual passing line you know he
does mention that cyborg is going to
speak his mind in this movie
so it's totally possible man yeah he's
going to talk against
joss whedon the entire time in this
movie
he's going to be cyborg is going to be
breaking the fourth wall just talking
about real controversy let me tell you
what really happened
on the theatrical cut cyborg is not too
happy what's going on with his life
before he meets the justice league and
he tends to speak his mind steppenwolf
is pretty much just
hacking people in half so the rating
would be due to violence and profanity
probably both i mean i think you could
get away with
one f word in a pg-13 movie depending on
the context
yes you can't say an f-u but you can say
go f yourself it's like the weirdest
thing
yeah it's like you can't allude to any
actual tangible
activities of the sexy variety but you
can tell people to do it to themselves
yeah you can or you can use it as just
like a placeholder word you know to make
things
spicy you can even say like f off yeah
but you can't
say f you know give me the f in money
man
yeah it's bizarre you know you can't you
can't use it two-pointedly otherwise the
kids are gonna get the wrong idea or
maybe batman just says
fu yeah i like the idea of showing
steppenwolf as a more
menacing villain who's slicing and
dicing in blood and gore to really
elevate the threat level
of this character i don't remember like
a significant amount of major human
casualties in the cut that we got from
whedon but maybe in that opening battle
with ooxas at the beginning maybe that
there'll be more blood and gore there to
really represent uh
harrowing war effects there's obviously
more
more scenes in here than what's even
been leaked or reported about so
maybe we'll get some more violence and
stuff in there but i'm always down for
more violence dude i i i love violence
i am always more down for it i mean that
warehouse scene in bbs
that was pretty violent and uh if he
just takes it up to the next notch there
with that a level of violence
i think i'm gonna be super happy about
it he also says i'm a huge fan and a big
supporter of the cinematic experience
and we're already talking about justice
league playing theatrically
at the same time it's coming to hbo max
so weirdly
it's the reverse of the trend
i mean and people will show up for that
is the thing
that's what i mean it's gonna be like a
four hour movie you're going to be
watching in the theater so
audience is tuned in for marathons and
such so
i'm wondering will he go all out will he
do
a man of steel bvs
and a snyder cup oh yeah they got to i
mean that's the
they would definitely bring people out
they would be able to make that extra
money because they could charge
more for the marathon and make money off
of two movies that have already run
their course and they didn't have to pay
any extra money to make
i could see this working out better for
them than tenant in a weird way because
i think there is just that contingency
of people who have
fought for this who will show up as like
an extraordinary circumstance
i mainly just hope now that it doesn't
mean the movie is gonna disappear up its
own behind and become just like the
stereotype of what you expect a zack
snyder fantasy to be just like
hard r gritty dark and just like
nihilistic to the core i still hope this
movie has some breathable dynamics and
whatnot
that's the only worry this brings to my
mind what
are you talking about of course it's
going to be those things you're speaking
about
that's why we're all looking forward to
dvs time i mean come on i mean the
people who've been championing for the
snyder cut are
defenders of those movies you know i
really do love man of steel even
when i could see it's problems and then
uh the bvs ultimate cut i did quite
enjoy
much better so yeah i think it's going
to be full
on zack snyder but i think it'll still
be
way more fun than man of steel and bvs i
think
it's gonna have a lot more of those
darker tones but you gotta have that
batman comedy that was in the weeding
cannot see he got the flash in there
you gotta people with sarcasm and such
and even in the first
comic-con trailer that was released
before snyder left that trailer was
still
really fun it had that white white
stripe song
yeah it had the white stripe song over
it and it had some humor in there
and that one was like all right this is
like a badass time but here's my thing
where's the sexuality talk
where's all this i mean watchman it was
in watchmen they had that there
i mean he does it in 300. why can't we
get the holy trinity scene
you know definitely yeah she with you i
thought she was with you
oh well let's just all get along she's
with
us we're with you how cool
would that be that would be a real step
that's what unleashes the mother box
no we're gonna work in the plot
continuity the mommy box that is yeah i
think about it
mama boxes in all sincerity i am very
excited for this snyder cut
i've been wanting it i've been
championing for it and put something on
our community
post page and i know that still there's
a divide not
i don't think it's like 50 50 as it once
was
but there's definitely still a good
chunk of people who are
very much like they they hate this news
f-bomb batman which i don't think is a
big deal like hey i mean why would he
not ever do
is that part of his code that's the
easiest aspect of that of that uh
uh attitude zack snyder put out before
about like these aren't your you know
innocent heroes of the past i'm like of
course batman's gonna swear
out of everything we've heard of snyder
say about
here's what happened my batman in prison
or something like that all the crazy
things zack snyder has said it seemed
like
especially on social media the main
thing
that people were the most reactive to
was batman saying an f-word
and i'm like that represents his moral
compass
that's such a in a different way than
killing people
he's likely to have said that he's a
grown man he's likely to have said
he's under his breath like climbing
stuff just like in the difficulties of
the job
even just without the context of saying
it to another person
i have two rules don't kill
and don't say
in case kids are around to witness
justice i don't want them to be
corrupted by me
it's not a big deal guys it's funny like
the idea is funny when you like go back
and rewrite scenes in your head and you
just include the f word there
it just sounds like he hasn't fought us
not us [ __ ] you know
like stupid [ __ ] like that it sounds
really funny it just sounds like
something your friend in high school
would have said like oh
my batman he's going to say the f word
yeah like ooh
cool i guess like it doesn't i mean it
does kind of read that way in the
context of just especially pulling a
quote
zack snyder has been compared to uh to
to like filmmakers of the college dorm
filmmakers you know
yeah you want edgy batman you want to
say some f words in this [ __ ]
i've read enough to make it here as
though this is
deep but really i just want to make him
curse and do
cool [ __ ] and sepia tone see it's not
i don't think it's that big a deal and
if it is rated r
i that gets me more excited helps
differentiate it that lets me
even know further that yeah they really
are letting zack snyder do whatever he
really wants to do with this
we've all seen no or at least most of us
have seen
films of his that weren't so well
received and then you watch extended
cuts which are more
r-rated beyond just being extended in
terms of you know the amount of scenes
and stuff
those are generally they're usually
better
if not a lot better so yeah that's right
and here's another reason why it's not a
big surprise to me that this is
happening is because it looks like all
the dc
shows are shifting over to hbo max i
mean that's how i watch
all of doom patrol which is very hard
r it's extremely hard r even the harley
quinn animated show
is extremely hard r
my point with this is like if it's the
snyder cup being on hbo max i'd expect
nothing less
if all the other dc content they're
putting over there is going with the r
rating this this isn't a big deal and if
it's
actually within brand of the dc original
content being over on hbo max
just makes sense to me i think this is a
good thing i'm i'm not opposed to this
at all
and i feel like it's something to get
excited about and not throw our arms up
in the air about
i feel like this is the point of doing
the schneider god is to let him do
his thing yeah man and especially with
talking about how it's the more adult
version
we'll see hey that's that's a way to go
all right guys well zack snyder's
justice league
have you seen it what do you think
[Laughter]
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell hit the like button
last but not least
scuba steve excited to be doing a
patreon day shop for you scuba
you've been a part of our patreon page
for quite some time now
very long time and one of our most loyal
patron jacks
so i wanted to wish you your family
and whoever you love in your life a
merry freaking christmas
because you've earned it man you've
earned it scuba
i want you to know you're my new best
friend
the best i've always wanted to fondle
you
wait i've always thought fondly of you
ah
and i've always thought that you had a
great ass
great ass it's true that's true scoops
it's al pacino from heat that's what i'm
quoting
the scuba i want you to know
that one day you're gonna spray paint
a venereal what's called a mural a mural
of a mural of us
a mural of us yes it's gonna be
beautiful
you know why gorgeous you're my best
friend absolutely best friend
and you're one of the best people around
you're doing some high-risk work out
there
you're looking out for people who are
vulnerable the hell are you talking
about is my best friend
that's true you're looking out for
greg's vulnerable
ego by being there for him you know
pretending to listen
and uh you know making that mural thanks
scuba scoobs
you know